hey guys dr. Burke here in this short
video I'm going to talk about pH the big
question is how do you know if you're
too alkaline or too acid and that's a
good question because even when people
tell you you're too acid and you need to
alkalize it it's not necessarily always
the fact because what what body fluid
are you talking about I mean are you
talking about the blood which normally
should be slightly alkaline or you talk
about the stomach which is extremely
acid or the urine that should be
slightly acid or the bile that should be
alkaline or the large bowel that should
be acid so you always want to determine
what pH you talking about what I'm
talking about is the blood pH the blood
page should normally be slightly
alkaline and if it's just a little bit
too excessively alkaline you can get all
these symptoms right here if it's a
little less than that it could still be
on the up and side but just not as
alkaline you can be more acidic so
that's basically all the symptoms that
can occur if your blood pH is too far
this way versus too far this way okay so
let's just talk about symptoms you can
use symptoms versus rather than like a
pH thing for your saliva or your urine
because how you going to check your
blood you know it's really an expensive
test and by the time you take the blood
out of your body it oxidizes with the
oxygen and the pH shifts so it's really
hard to detect that so I like to use
symptoms first okay so if you're too
acid you could have possibly chest pain
palpitations because it affects the the
electrolyte mix headaches anxiety muscle
weakness bone pain joint pain and air
hungry like like your can't get enough
air okay and then alkaline would be
excessively aqua be much muscle twitches
like tetany that little twitch right
here or on the arm allergies muscle
spasms muscle cramps muscle weakness why
because the calcium is all locked up
you're going to calcium build up to
dehydration because you need this the
electrolytes need to be hydrated
correctly that the pH is off to alkaline
you can't mobilize electrolytes muscle
pain and also difficulty breathing this
would this
be more of a hyperventilation just it's
just a difficulty with breathing but
sometimes it's it's difficult because
you might have some of these in some of
some of these so there's one quick way
to determine what way you are all you
have to do is drink some apple cider
vinegar like two tablespoons and some
water with a straw drink that and see if
some of these issues clear up and you
feel better and if you do that means
that you're too alkaline or let's assume
that you're too acid take some calcium
citrate or calcium magnesium and see if
you don't feel better it's a quick way
to determine what pH you are so that's a
that's one way that you can do it so
it's you don't necessarily have to do an
expensive test and some people I just
give them a little calcium magnesium or
lactate and boom like half these things
clear right up but the ultimate thing to
do is to get on the right eating plan
and your body will bring your pH to the
correct balance now as we're talking
about symptoms and causes I have a quiz
down below in the description box that's
104 questions go ahead and take this
quiz and I will send you a report to
tell you what's going on with your body
all right thanks for watching